benyamin nétanyahou revendique la
victoire aux législatives selon les
derniers sondages à la sortie des urnes
le leader du likoud et premier ministre
israélien récolte ray plus de sièges que
son rival du parti bleu blanc benny
gantz
des résultats qui le place en position
de force pour former le prochain
gouvernement ait affrontée par ailleurs
la justice qu'ils accusent de corruption
on écoute benyamin nétanyahou je vous ai
dit que c'était une victoire contre
toute attente car nous nous sommes
opposés à des forces puissantes nos
adversaires avaient déjà fait notre
nécrologie et avait déclaré que l'ère
natanyahou était terminée j'ai parlé
plus tôt avec tous les chefs de partis
du bloc de droite après avoir dormi un
peu nous nous réunirons demain afin de
commencer à former le plus tôt possible
un gouvernement fort et stable
un bon gouvernement national pour l'état
d'israël
et réaction ce matin à jérusalem des
partisans du premier ministre et forums
je pense qu'il a gagné la confiance de
la majorité des gens et à côté de ça
d'autres rejettent ses idées c'est
ambivalent mais il faut se rappeler que
ce n'est pas le résultat final encore
c'est une grande victoire personnelle
pour netanyahou en tout cas c'est sûr
[Musique]
les résultats de cette élection nous
rend tous heureux on regarde vers un
meilleur futur vers un jérusalem plus
stable et seront on est très heureux de
se réveiller ce matin avec ses résultats
qui permettent à netanyahu de former le
prochain gouvernement
on voit maintenant qu'il a probablement
61 sièges à la knesset une majorité peut
être 62 on est très très heureux on lui
souhaite bonne chance et on espère qu'il
tiendra ses promesses que ce soit une
réponse du système judiciaire israélien
alexandre la vallée du jourdain la judée
et la samarie
cette vie son électorat avec la promesse
d'un excès des territoires notamment
ceux de la cisjordanie occupée
écoutez à ce propos mustafa barghouti ch
secrétaire général de l'initiative
nationale palestinienne
netanyahu a fait tout ce qu'il pouvait
pour mobiliser ses partisans à se
déplacer et voter pour lui
d'un autre côté il ya un constat très
important la communauté arabe les
palestiniens vivant en israël ont
également voté en très grand nombre
cela ne s'était pas produit depuis très
longtemps
tous les palestiniens d'israël sont unis
dans une seule liste ce qui leur
garantit entre 14 et 15 sièges ce qui le
plus grand nombre jamais obtenue est le
principal rival de benyamin nétanyahou
benny ganz à lui ai exprimé sa déception
[Musique]
je comprends et je partage votre
sentiment de déception et de douleur de
ne pas avoir le résultat attendu
si les résultats sont définitifs il ne
le ramèneront pas israël sur la bonne
voie
mais dès lundi c'est l'aider à meslay
car en laval le parti bleu blanc ne fait
que démarrer
nous venons de commencer nous avons
encore un très long chemin à parcourir
nous plierons pas nous continuerons à
servir l'état d'israël
[Musique]